and you touched on a great topic you
don't get whisked away to your new city
overnight you're gonna be sitting
wherever it was you were when you were
drafted indefinitely
think of how hard that's gonna make it
for these guys to get up to speed in
their first NFL seasons I mean what's
gonna be really strange I think Mike is
that you look at and and you know
wherever Justin Herbert gets drafted
okay I don't think that the assumption
is that and let's say you keep the
schedule the way it is I don't think the
assumption is that on September 13th
he's gonna be the starting quarterback
all right but what do you think the
assumption is in Cincinnati what do you
think the assumption is assuming they
take Joe borough and there's a slight
chance he'd get traded but I think it's
only slight but Cincinnati is drafting
Joe burrow to be the quarterback of the
team they're not drafting Joe burrow so
that they could get trade of four or get
a four for Andy Dalton or let Ryan
Finley keep the seat warm
you know while while Joe borough learns
and so that is what's going to be the
most difficult thing just imagine if
there's no offseason program other than
a virtual one where you're using zoom or
or Cisco whatever Microsoft teams to
learn your playbook and then the first
time you meet let's say AJ Green is on
you know August 17th at the start of
training camp in whatever form that's
going to take so that those are the guys
the guys will have to step in on day one
or who are expected to step in on day
one and play that's who it's gonna
really hurt hey and if I'm Joe burrow
one of the first guys I'm calling after
the draft is Cam Newton because Cam
Newton had to do basically that in 2011
as the first overall pick during the
lockout nothing happened until training
camp and Newton came in started right
away was spectacular out of the gates
so whatever Cam Newton did it worked and
I would want to pick his brain Peter and
find out what he did
to get ready for his first season
because it's gonna be apples to apples
although burros gonna have a little more
of that benefit of doing the the
learning from home Cam Newton didn't
even have that and Cam Newton was able
to be great right away well the
difference I think is that first of all
Cam Newton would have been able in the
three months before training camp
started I think it was July 27th he
would have been able at that time to
have full workouts with other receivers
and other players and I have no idea
when Joe burrow is going to be able to
get out on a football field and throw to
receivers who he's gonna play with and
again I'm not saying any of that I'm not
saying any of it is impossible I we
don't know what's going to happen but I
just think that missing you know the
last week of April all of May and half
of June you know before you take a
little hiatus before training camp that
is gonna hurt the guys who are expected
to step in on day one and play and again
I try to be pragmatic with everything
that's going on is relates to the
pandemic but I think these guys are
gonna find a way to work out with their
teammates as long as they don't post it
on social media it won't become a major
issue but I think these quarterbacks
from Tom Brady all the way down to Joe
burrow and all in between if they're
conscientious about their craft they are
going to find a way even if they are
violating state and local orders
requiring folks to stay at home and out
of facilities during the pendent
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports